fine so this is from one month my to or
from form 1 252 I still got on
horizontal major axis but I've rinsed it
off what happens if I walk around with
this instead let's go back to the center
at the origin and what if I wanted to
stretch out this way what if i want the
vertical axis to be the major axis what
all happens you might not know if you
can take to wait I thought you can just
leave it like that you can say well
instead of a being the bigger number B
will be the bigger number and that's
fine ok I personally prefer to write it
like this oops what i've done here is
i've stayed to set up right so there's
the center of the lips but I've moved
the major axis to be vertical instead
now let me justify for you why I prefer
this way ok so this is a vertical major
axis my age is my be another that's
telling me my own x y intercept ok the
reason why I prefer it like this is
because when you have to UM find out
like where the foci and director sees
all our lives ok if you and let's come
back to this guy if you have a look at
this right you color just do it straight
away you've got the AV that's the
proportions but you need one other piece
of third thing you need the eccentricity
do you remember that how do i get the
eccentricity out of there it's the first
thing that I do v square equals 2a
squared outside of one takeaway you
spent ok good no this is fine it's
always worked okay but significantly
this only works it is the bigger number
right a has to be bigger watch what
happens right let's just suppose I'm go
now think about this so this guy this
guy has the major axis vertical butt
stretched out that way is there let's
just see what happens if I try putting
is all that is the
so my and the bees that why not that's
that's what it looks like over there was
trying to stay with that form watch what
happens do the numbers ring okay this is
going to be 16 this is going to be nice
yeah so far so good I get 16 online
equals want to take away you sweat yeah
at this point I said okay look I
actually want to work out e so and I
want to get all of the constants of all
tight so I'm going to swap the e squared
and thus if they don't know I'm gonna
move that way okay so I respective
better sides he ends up over here and
then i subtract 16 on nine what does
that leave you with on the right hand
side haters negative seven or not okay
this is a problem right I mean as
extension to students we know how to
deal with this kind of except we don't
want to we want the eccentricity just to
be a ratio and we know and ellipses
supposed to give us these kinds of
things right so therefore you're like a
problem you can't really go through this
and attach the a and the B to the X and
the y in fact if you think about it like
what's the difference between this lives
which looks like it is and the ellipse I
had before or the one who did as an
example which looks like this okay in
terms of the proportions the proportions
are the same the eccentricity the amount
that this is a way from a circle is
still the same it's just the orientation
that has changed so therefore when you
look at this this crucial crucial
relationship we went to great lengths to
establish right a squared must be the
bigger man bar and B squared must be the
smaller number in other words this has
to represent the major axis and this has
to represent the minor axis now remember
i said to you some textbooks like the
wall that actually gave you a on the
head out at all we'll stick with this
ball and they'll say look a has to be
the X number and B has to be the wire
number when they get to this and I
encounter this problem they say okay no
problem just swap them swap them okay
now i find that mad at me okay wouldn't
it have been easier to just say what a
slave
be the big number it's always been
subpoenaed billion other and so
therefore you you switch there by
recognizing that it's actually different
okay now if you feel a bit uncomfortable
that maybe you're used to just having it
this way and just putting your Airways
which ever way of doing the swap then go
for it okay but I kind of feel like this
being such a crucial relationship and
we're going to meet him in another form
as well when we go to the next cloning
right I think it's better not to think
about I'm just gonna randomly switch I
think it makes more sense to say as the
major piece of work well you have to
that's what we have then you get this
point and you have to remember to them
there they say I play the switch them
okay which I feels more arbitrate to me
just kind of like when you could be a
little raised where you just check if
it's like pressuring you think I should
get my own teaching feel like which is
the same thing like you you catch my
error you'll catch it one or two lines
earlier have it there you and you start
the same problem you still gonna do some
kind of strange okay so what have I done
we started from our basic form centered
at the origin horizontal major axis we
look to what happens in which
translators we look at what happens if
we stretch this way instead of this way
what do you think is my fourth and final
four I feel like I put come on the
fourth and final form of my it's going
to be the combination of those right
it's a translation and I want the
vertical major axis instead of a
horizontal so therefore it's going to
look like this
okay so this has both of the changes
right you've got the center somewhere
else and you also have a vertical major
axis ok now we're not quite finished in
talking about these be close once you
know all of these things right you can
then read off read off the foci and the
direct receipts from their fault okay so
now let's rewind let's go back here
we're gonna go all the way through these
four forms suppose I should finish off
the boob it we're going to go through
all three four forms and work out where
the director seeds and foci are for each
form and we'll start with the easiest
one that we already know this is also
and I'm just going to go across my
whiteboard tu caso de lo que você
director sees right so here for the
original form what did we already
establish the foci are at what points
along the major axis where are they
there are plus or minus AE comma 0 okay
do you remember that and here's the
important thing is who I started this
the [ __ ] I have to be on the major axis
as you say that because they're the ones
that have been stretched apart so if
they're being stretched that's what
makes this the longer axis okay so
that's where the profile and that helps
you remember okay well therefore the
director sees instead of being the
product hey it's the quotient rights the
division um plus or minus a on in what's
customized any which way the drew the
director she's go if I've got a
horizontal my consciousness yeah it's
going to be x equals plus or minus a or
e okay so do you see why it makes two
big deal about like where's the major
axis if you know where the major axis is
going
sway then you know these have to be on
the major actors and these have been
shifted across horizontally see X
horizontal retroactively so now I can
fall available from the first one to the
second form what's different is that I
have translated okay so therefore
instead of the foci being a plus or
minus AE equal 0 they're going to move
this much you see that they can move
that much to the right and this much of
words okay so therefore the foci are not
going to be around zero plus or minus
they're going to be around h plus or
minus okay so therefore I've got each
fossil minus AE and then of course
they're not on my exes access anymore we
got wherever you put them which is that
ok does that make sense you see how i've
incorporated this horizontal and
vertical translation into the Photon
same deal with the director sees these
directories are perpendicular to the
horizontal major axis which means
they're vertical lines right effect i
have them over here here are my vertical
lines so therefore it doesn't matter how
much you shift them up and down do you
agree with that if they're vertical line
thing you're up and down however much
and there's still the same vertical line
so what really matters is how much had
been horizontally shifted right so
they're not going to be at plus or minus
AE anymore they're going to be at edge
plus or minus ok this is where you said
top right this is really i mean i
suppose i could write this as 0 plus or
minus ay ay and that's the zeros your
center and then you go in the two
directions but here you've got a new
center i wonder if you could finish this
off you're never going to the fourth
will by yourself once i get to this one
I think let's think about this time
right I've gone back to Center in the
origin right but remember I said the
foci are both on the major axis in this
case what's the later answer 20
once the the matrix is the way out it's
gone this way okay so therefore your
phone is still going to stay 0 on the
y-axis but they move up and down right
up and down up to durkins so you get
plus or minus AE attaching to the by now
yep and your directory ceased being that
they must be perpendicular to your axis
of symmetry I mean just like they are
for a blog right the dresses are not
going to be x equals anymore they're not
going to be vertical lines they're going
to be y equals they can be horizontal
line y equals plus or minus a on a ok
I'm going to discuss I think you can see
what's going to happen in the last one
there's still that same horizontal
vertical shift happening like so